I've had a couple cutie patooties come and try to comment on my stuff
because some other, like,
Grifter Fucking Creator that just likes to take people's videos and,
like, stir up drama used one of mine.
And I'm gonna address the issue.
This. I'm gonna address the bullshit
because it is total bullshit.
So if you're a stepmom
coming here to talk shit about how great stepmoms are,
you could kindly leave. Um,
we're only here for the girls. Girls.
So I'll get to it. But you're just, like,
not a priority for me, because the.
The woman's content, literally
all she does is take somebody's video and then make up details
and then tell you this big story,
but she don't know shit about fuck.
So you little miss willpower,
go willpower your ass somewhere else,
and I'll address all the bullshit in her dumbass video
when I fucking get to it.